leaving the European Union would be a
jump into a void for the UK those are
the words of a new group of conservative
MPs fighting to stay within the European
Union now it comes as a poll this
morning has given the out campaign a
six-point lead the highest it's been
since the general election well I'm
joined now by the former Chancellor is
of course Lord Lawson now president of
the Euroskeptic group conservatives for
Britain so you've got a counter that
argument very good morning to you Lord
Lawson for more ninja leap into the void
it's extraordinary expression because of
course it's not a void it's a place
called the world and we know the world
quite well it's not out of space and we
do to enormous amount of business all
over the world we trade with the world
we invest they invest in us we have all
manner of links and indeed because the
European market sadly is something of a
disaster zone at the moment trade with
the rest of the world is growing fast
still to the majority of our trade with
the European no it's not the majority
but it is a lot but and it only accounts
for about fifteen percent of our total
economy because of course a lot of our
economy is trade within the our own
country but it's we will carry on I
don't know whether you ever have time in
your busy life to go shopping but if you
do you will find goods on the shelves
from all over the world you don't have
to be within the European Union to trade
with the European Union that is a
complete nonsense so really the question
is would we do better outside and I have
no doubt that we would quite apart from
the fact that it is primarily a
political project it's not an economic
project that's one of the reasons why
it's no good it's a political project
and a perfectly legitimate one but is
one whose objective we don't share but
as I mean you know I've got to throw
this at you because of course as a
poacher turned gamekeeper as Chancellor
shadowed the deutsche mark in
preparation for trying to join the
forerunner of the euro the exchange rate
mechanism you've changed of you because
you then presumably you thought it was
primary and economic organization no I
didn't I'd all doubt i'd written did it
was a political
but the difference is that when I was
shadowing the deutsche mark i think this
lovely old hat but when i was shouting
the deutsche mark it was a matter of
keeping our own currency what has
happened now is there is a monetary
union a currency unit the eurozone and
this has changed the dynamics totally is
there anything that the Prime Minister
can bring back from Brussels that would
change you and your supporters mind
we're hearing now that you know there's
a lot of progress being made shackled
yonkers saying we think a deal can be
done that perhaps Britain could become
this is further in there in the room of
Britain could become some kind of
second-tier member of the European Union
and keep those economic links i have
read very carefully what david cameron's
asked for in his letter to president
tusk of the european union and even in
my judgment even if he gets a hundred
percent of what he's asked for and it
sound like he'll get more than antrim
stone but we shall see even if he gets a
hundred percent of what he's asked for
it is inconsequential just as in 1975
Harold Wilson came back and conned the
people of this country into believing he
secured a fundamental reform when of
course he hadn't so you'll draw
parallels with you think the plan mr.
Cameron House they can't come back and
and pump up inflate what he's got I
suspect that may be the case yes but i
don't think the british people will be
so keen to be conned a second time okay
well what do you think then also about
the nature of the campaign he said once
the deal whatever shape that takes he's
done it of course technically the prime
minister says he could still vote
against it that looks pretty unlikely
but within his own cabinet his his own
ministers they will then be free to
campaign according to their conscience
but up to this point we're talking to
people like you not cabinet members who
have doubts about membership of the
European Union because they're not
allowed to speak out yet but they are
going to be able to speak out and they
will speak out and that's good and
that's healthy and it's also very
important
because whatever the result of the
referendum and in my judgment it's
likely to be pretty close either way
whatever the result of the referendum
the Conservative Party will need to come
together again and carry on governing on
a whole range of issues on which it is
completely united in which it is it
necessary for the British people that it
should continue to govern once this is
over so David Cameron was very sensible
to allow members of cabinet to do there
and think campaign the way they feel is
right and I believe that it is clear in
my mind what is right and and also i
think the british people are concerned
that the European Union is such a
profoundly undemocratic institution we
in this country ever have an addiction
to democracy and we like to feel though
we have self-government and that's what
the immigration issues about whether we
have control of our own border I mean
just the addiction to democracy and in a
long way at last is of course all about
really about face and on the issue of
fairness just on the on what the Prime
Minister has allowed hasn't he given
though that the Euro supporters a year
of files a head start they're allowed
campaign they're allowed to speak out
were just about to to speak to one of
them next yes I think well I I think
that perhaps he has but I there are so
many bigger issues at stake that I don't
want to start arguing about that it is
the fundamental it is the future of our
country which is at stake and it is I
have no doubt whatever the politically
and economically on both fronts we would
do far better outside it we're a big
country we are the fifth biggest economy
in the world we have a lot of clout and
the idea that we're Sam I like Norway or
something like that is ludicrous anyone
who understands the ounce of rail
politique knows that we
could do very very well outside but just
let me ask you about the leadership of
your campaign you feel it's important
that as we've been discussing here
that's the discussion the argument the
debate is catch friend mainly by the
economy and you have said in the past
you don't want the xenophobes to be seen
to be leading the campaign now I think
that when it comes to the quite clearly
there the campaign will be led by a
probably by both a member of the present
cabinet and also by some very
experienced senior business men who know
that we would prosper more outside the
European Union any names for that member
of the cabinet you will find out in due
course what about you keep you don't
want Nigel Farage involvement no he's
doing his own thing you keep doing their
own thing but they have a different
perspective from from perspective that
we have and the big issue is who will be
designated by the Electoral Commission
as the leave the campaign group and I
have no doubt it'll be us but could you
keep I'm and give it that the center
phobic changes like so this is a free
country he's entitled to do his own
thing I disagree with a lot of what he
says but and say this is a free country
and long may remain sir are great to see
you Lord Lawson thank you very much a
deep feeling time well as I was saying
that we just heard from the you're a
skeptic side of the debate one a new
group conservatives for reform in Europe
has been created to back David Cameron's
renegotiations and lead the fight to
stay in the EU I'm joined now by its
leader Nick Herbert set very good to see
mr. been listening very closely I know
they're to Lord Lawson I mean do you
feel or Lawson you know I asked him
there about you you've been given a head
start those within your party that
disagree with you and think the Prime
Minister is not going to get anything
worthwhile and we should vote leave
they're not allowed to speak out
properly yet well ministers are not
going to be speaking out but of course
the rest of us can and the reason that I
thought it was so important to start
this group is that there
there are some people in this country
who will want to say let's stay in the
European Union regardless just as they
said let's join the euro regardless and
I thought they were wrong about that at
the time and set up a campaign to say no
we should not join the euro that was
would have been very bad for our economy
but we should stay in the single market
and then there's another group that want
to leave come what may and some for some
of them it's their lifelong ambition to
leave but I think there is a very large
group of people in the country and
certainly in the Conservative Party who
have no love for the European Union have
some concerns about it actually about
the growth in the regulation and issues
like competitiveness and certainly
issues of great public concern like
migration that we feel quite strongly
must be addressed so we want reform in
the European Union and provided that
there is significant reform we would
then be willing to say yes when it comes
to the choice we should stay in but I
don't think we are unconditional support
now of the European unity nice actually
where I think I just probably honest
about it it's interesting what you're
saying there then because you know I
suppose the the popular view and you
know more about your own party of course
the than I do it's the sense that within
the Conservative Party especially ones
made up their minds you know they're
either in or out whatever the prime
minister gets you're actually saying
something very different that there's a
lot of your colleagues who are looking
very closely what the Prime Minister
brings back from Brussels and will vote
according to that because of course the
Prime Minister hasn't yet said which way
he'll go exactly the the Prime Minister
has says that he rules nothing out and
that's important and it's very important
that our European partners know that
that there is a very substantial body of
people who want to be in a position to
say yes we will stay but only if we get
the vital reforms that we need and I
think that if we do Britain could be in
a very advantageous position because we
would find that we were outside of the
eurozone and we would be protected from
the deeper integration that countries
like Germany and France want to do to
protect their currency the euro that's
been a big concern but we would be in
the single market and that is a market
of 500 million people it's the world's
greatest market and it is a real issue
about whether we
have anything like the same kind of art
of advantages for our businesses if we
were forced out I've got to be prepared
to say given what you've just said now
you've got to be prepared to say to me
here that if the Prime Minister doesn't
get enough you be prepared to join Lord
Lawson I said this morning and I I said
last year and many of my colleagues feel
the same way that if the deal was not
satisfactory we would be put in a
position where we would be willing to
contemplate leaving and the Prime
Minister has said that he rules nothing
out it is important that people
understand that but if we can get this
deal and address the issues that people
do mind about like the drawer of people
from within the European Union in terms
of migration and the prime minister said
he wants to tackle that by reducing the
amount of time that they can it would
that be a deal breaker i mean that is
one of the key issues at the pub I think
to tag an exam on that the four-year
freeze its own benefits wearing that
might already be in the back to tackle
that kind of issue I think would be
absolutely fundamental because it's key
to public concern and I think it would
be a very popular move to say look we
are not going to pay in work benefits
which can be worth thousands of pounds a
year to people that are coming over with
having never paid into the system that
would be an issue of fairness but it
would also I think helped to reduce the
pull factor of people coming over from
within the European Union if we can
address that if we can address this
issue of the fact that at the moment
there's ever closer union is part of the
formal ambition of the European Union
the prime minister said he wants a an
agreement that that will stop that
Britain will not be committed to ever
closer union if we can get a formal
commitment to deregulation and to
increase competitiveness what about yeah
i mean just staying with migrations
already throw it in there yet in some
papers a day as well the the emergency
brake on EU migration EU member state
migration that might be back on on the
time well the problem sir said he's
open-minded about the mechanism and if
there are alternative mechanisms then
they should be looked at and that will
all be part of the process of
renegotiation I think that what I feel
and what I'm sure many people in the
country will feel is what what they want
is the issue brought back under control
they want to reduce the numbers that are
coming from within the EU and if it is
an emergency brake rather than
addressing the pull factor
it's both of those things then that that
would be good it's the package that
matters and remember the those that
really want to leave the European Union
they're very quick so will the reforms
don't add up to anything but that's not
what our European partners are saying at
all and the President of the European
Council Donald Tusk when he responded to
the Prime Minister's initial letter
saying look this is what we must have
said these are significant and
far-reaching reforms some of which will
be very difficult so this will be a
tough negotiation and my judgment is
that if we get broadly though totality
of these reforms which include more of a
safer national parliaments as well which
is very important not only will we have
stopped this relentless drive to deeper
you know an integration indapur we would
have actually turned it round as well
and fatties particularly a moonbow thing
to our constituents I just want actually
lastly about somehow the group came
about as it formed organically and
autonomously or have there been
discussions with number 10 one would
suspect that they would not be
displeased with this I don't think that
because it's forming I don't of course I
discussed this with the with the Prime
Minister and I the group wants to
support his renegotiation we're saying
that we think he's doing the right thing
by promising the referendum lots of
people said that there would never be a
referendum we wouldn't deliver on that
promise we did Lord are you sell a good
i'll share discuss another time minister
did are you then the Prime Minister's
instrument will you go the way the prime
minister says or could you ultimately
say well okay primaries do you think
you've got enough we don't know every
conservative member pilot will make up
their own minds and our group will make
up its own mind we've had lots of
discussions with members of parliament
and peers and members of the party more
broadly what they want is a voice for
their view which i think is the view
that doesn't say we'll go in stay in
come what may or will leave come away
but actually we want reform and if there
is serious reform in the European Union
then we would be willing to stay and I
think we speak for a lot of people in
the party and the country by taking that
view